欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们 这一节课我们主要来学习一下关于爆款标题的组合实战系统
学完了这个系统之后 我们不仅能够知道我们标题的一些基本的概念
标题的一些基本的组合方式 我们还能够学会如何去制造一些爆款的标题
同时这一章节我会讲六种爆款标题的主要方法
我们只要学会其中的一两种就已经够我们使用了
那么下面我们就开始正式的讲解
首先我们来看一下标题它就是一个产品的一个排序的一个核心
产品的名称是买家搜索的第一匹配要素
也就是标题就是产品的名称
标题才是最核心的搜索要素 因为客户搜索的时候是不是首先他是会通过关键词去搜 搜了之后是不是系统就会去提取我们产品的标题来进行一个综合的数据的比配 才能够把这些产品按照竞争度大小 从上往下进行一个排序 所以说就会出现 搜关键词就会出现产品的排名 是吧
就是这个逻辑 我们来看一下它的这几个核心的概念 第一个概念是什么关键词 其实它就是等于产品信息 也就是我们在标题中所用的这些词 其实都是在展示我们的产品信息 第二个就是买家的需求表达就是等于关键词 也就是当买家收关键词 比如说A或者是B的时候 B关键词的时候
他们的需求是不一样的 表达的需求是不一样的 所以说关键词也是买家需求的表达 第三个就是标题 它是由多个关键词组合形成的一个关键词集合 关键词集合其实就是我们所说的这个标题 它是由很多很多关键词组合在一起的 形成一个集合 第四个呢 就是标题是整个产品详情页中最核心的权重
匹配是以标题的关键词为核心的
就是当客户搜索关键词的时候
比如说搜索A跟B的时候
这些都是开始匹配的
都是以我们的这个标题最开始为匹配的要素的
所以说我们一定要重视这个标题的写法
以及标题的用词
只有我们把这个标题做好了
那么我们才能够让我们的这个产品链接覆盖到更多的关键词 以及覆盖到更多的流量 才能够获得更大的流量和排名的机会
所以说一定要把这个标题的一个排序的核心一定要记住以及理解它是最重要的 标题是最重要的 重要的事情说三次就是标题它是第一匹配要素
那么接下来就是标题的一个权重 标题权重 我们来看一下 当我们打开一个产品链接的时候 是不是会出现这样的一条链接 这样的一条链接 那你看后面是不是每个产品都有一个ID
这个ID其实就是存储 存储我们产品所有信息的一个编码 就是这个产品的ID 就是存储整个产品所有的数据 比如说你产品的
曝光 点击 询盘 订单 以及 访客 等等这些数据都会存储在这里面 所以说 我们的这个ID不变的时候 那么我们整个产品的数据就不会变 你看这个链接里面 前面这一部分是标题的前半部分 后面这个ID的部分是隐藏了 把这一部分后面的这些关键词的数据隐藏在里面
那么这个就表明如果我们在修改这个标题的某些关键词的时候
它是不会影响我们的ID的变化 但是它会影响这个ID的数据 它会影响这个产品的数据
所以我们在日常优化产品以及在调整标题的时候 一定要注意某些关键词是不要乱改动
也不要乱删减了 特别是一些好的爆品数据的产品的标题 一定不要乱改 或者是一定不要轻易删掉一些关键词
那么我们来解释一下关于权重的这个概念 什么是权重 权重就是指某个指标在平台系统中相对重要的一个程度
比如说标题在排序的规则中的重要程度是占比是最大 说明标题的权重就是最大 权重只是代表它的一个重要程度 理解吧这个意思
我们来解释一下什么指标 指标就是一个比如说排排名它是有很多因素决定的
那么你的标题只是其中的一个因素 所以每个指标对整个项目的影响程度是不同的
用数值123 表示数据越大 那么他的权重就越大 实际上我们是也没有办法对应的是到底他的数值是多大 我们是没有办法计算的 这些都是后台自己计算的 最后面呢 我们来看一下
有一个误区 我们一定要区分 首先第一个就是权重是不等于排名的 只表示这个指标的重要程度
第二个呢 就是权重对于排 关键词的排名是有一定的提升作用 在同等条件下 排名是优先的 也就是你的权重越高 那么你的排名就会有机会再靠前
这种类似就是一种加分的作用 第三个呢 就是整个站权重的提高有利于整个店铺的排名 理解吧
我们如果店铺各项综合数据都非常好的时候 那么就有利于我们整个店铺里面的所有的产品 或者是关键词 它的排名都会上升一个层次
所以说这是非常重要的一个权重 所以说我们在日常运营中 我们要重视店铺的一个权重 以及单品的一个权重 这些都是决定我们产品排名的
关键的一些因素 所以一定要重视起来 并且去落实到位
第三点 我们来看一下 系统他抓取标题权重的顺序是怎么样的 首先 第一个就是标题 第二个就是关键的 K1 K2 K3 第三个才是详情页的文本
这几个加起来 加上 店铺的权重跟单品的权重 那么就这两个加起来 那么就等于
我们的排名 排名 排名 就决定我们的排名 首先标题呢 它是最大的影响产品排名的权重 标题是最大的影响排名的权重 比如说我们标题中 你用的某些词 或者是说你用的词的总量多少 竞争度怎么样 都会决定你这个产品的排名 第一层首先 比如说当客户搜索A这个关键词的时候 第一层参与排名的一定是
标题中的关键词 标题中的关键词 它可以拆分成 N 种组合 形式是非常多样的
刚才我们上面一节已经讲了 关键产品的标题是大量关键词的集合组成的 所以说它会有很多种组合
所以无论你客户可能说 A 关键词还是 B 关键词还是 C 关键词 只要命中它的这些组合词的时候
都表示着这个产品有可能 就是参与排名 接着第二层参与排名的就是 如果你的标题中都有 你的同行也有 那么参与第二个排名的权重的就是 店铺的权重足够高 单品的足够高 以及你填写的K1 K2 K3的排序组合 都有机会参与排名 就是第一 你的标题都有 第二就是你的店铺权重高 你的单品权重高
或者是你的K1 K2 K3 里面都填有一些相关的关键词 那么它的相关度越高 那么它就有助于你排名第三层 如果你的单品店铺权重的很高 那么你的详情业中还有一些客户搜索的一些关键词的一些文字 那么这时候这些文字也参与排名 所以说从1 2 3 三层都参与排名的时候
那么都有与客户搜索的关键词相关的时候 那么你的总的排名就会更有利于提升
这就是系统抓取我们标题权重的一个顺序 就类似于详情页的一个重要程度
它会先从哪些地方体现出来 因为标题到关键词到详情页这些都是一个完整的产品详情页链接里面的内容
所以说他会根据这个链路进行一个捉取 进行排序 最后面就是你的店铺权重跟单铺权重是给到你这些排序的因子的一个加分的作用 你的店铺权重越高 单铺权重越高 那么你的这些加分的权益就越好 越高排名就越好